Hey everyone, Ryan here and welcome to this brand new series on operative dentistry.
Operative dentistry is central to the everyday life of a general dentist, and it's the art
and science of diagnosing defects of teeth, treatment planning these cases, and then treating
them with direct restorations to restore comfort, health, function, and aesthetics for the patient.
Now we're going to cover a lot of great topics in this series, and that being said, like
all my videos, I'm going to focus on the highest yield things that you need to know
to do well on the board exam.
My hope is that this set of videos will help you prepare for the board exam and also give
you a nice overview for clinical application and general knowledge.
So we're going to start by talking about what teeth are made out of, and we're going
to start the discussion with appetite.
Now this doesn't mean you're hungry in this case, but rather it's a classification of
naturally occurring phosphate minerals.
They're isomorphous, which means they all have the same crystallitis and molecular structure.
If we work through the math a little bit, the calcium ion is 2 plus, the phosphate group
over here is 3 minus, so we get 2 times 5 is 10 plus for all of the calcium in this
molecule, 3 minus we have 3 times, so that's 9 minus, so we need a minus 1 valence to make
this entire molecular group neutral.
And so we have a couple of choices.
We can do a hydroxyl group, a fluoride ion, or a chloride ion for some examples, and we're
going to focus on the first two.
And these correspond to the names of the types of appetite, depending on the group you're
using to substitute, hydroxyapitate, fluorapitate for fluoride, chlorapitate for chlorine.
So biological appetites refer to the particular appetite minerals that compose some of our
body structures, like enamel, dentin, and bone.
And there's a special hydroxyapitate that we'll talk about in a little bit that composes
our teeth and our bones.
So let's look at hydroxyapitate a little bit closer.
We substituted the hydroxyl group in order to make this molecule neutral, and then we
just doubled everything, we went from 5 to 10, 3 to 6, and so on from the previous slide.
And that's because that's how it's reported commonly in the literature.
And you can appreciate its hexagonal structure here and how the atoms are arranged within
the unit cell.
Pure hydroxyapitate powder is this white powder down here, and by itself it is biocompatible
for things like bone implants, but it has a low bio-resorption rate, which means it
doesn't quite mimic the inorganic portion of our bones and our teeth.
So then we talk about carbonate substituted hydroxyapitate, which is actually the main
component of enamel and dentin.
And it's carbonate substituted because we have these little CO3 carbonate groups that
are added into the mix.
This is our naturally occurring hydroxyapitate.
The tooth is about 85% hydroxylapitate by volume and 95% by weight, and that's because
it's a packed crystal that weighs relatively a lot for its small size.
If we're talking about enamel specifically, amyloblasts are literally stacking these unit
cells on top of each other during amylogenesis to form crystallites that create these long
enamel rods or enamel prisms.
Enamel rods are built with this keyhole pattern.
Interesting to note, each enamel rod has a head and a tail, and the tail tends to be
more organic and have less mineral content, and thus more susceptible to decay, which is
good to know for the board exam.
So carbonate substitution increases the solubility of the hydroxyapitate.
And enamel is structurally and compositionally different from site to site.
For example, the enamel tends to have more carbonate substitution here near the DEJ or
the dentin enamel junction, but it tends to be more fluoride substituted or fluorapitate
near the outside where fluoride can bathe the tooth with fluoridated water, mouth rinse,
and toothpaste.
We'll talk more about fluoride in a little bit, but the important thing here is that
the deeper a cavity penetrates into the tooth, the more soluble that enamel will be because
it has more carbonate substitution.
And don't worry, we're going to talk about that more in depth later in the video.
All right, so now we can talk about how cavities work, and this is super interesting.
I really hope you find this as fascinating as I do.
So there's an equilibrium that we can see here constantly going on between hydroxyapitate
in the tooth and the free calcium and phosphate ions that are floating around in the mouth
and in the plaque covering the teeth.
calcium and phosphate ions are constantly being traded back and forth from the tooth
to the mouth and the plaque and back to the tooth and so on.
Now we've always been told that sugar is bad for your teeth and will rot your teeth out
of your mouth, but I'm here to say that's not entirely true.
That's actually not the full picture.
So sugar by itself is actually a preservative.
It soaks up the water that many bacteria thrive in, and so it prevents the growth of microbes
that can spoil food like jams and jellies.
But our mouths are different and offer the perfect moist environment for bacteria with
lots of nooks and crannies for them to grow in.
Think about all the pits and fidgeters of your back teeth.
Special bacteria that cause caries, we call those karyogenic bacteria, digest these sugar
sugars that we consume for their own energy via glycolysis and then go one step further
to produce lactic acid via fermentation.
This organic acid, which is represented by this hydrogen ion here, so this is our acid,
is secreted directly onto the tooth enamel and is the actual culprit.
So these hydrogen ions complex with the free phosphate in the mouth to form phosphoric
acid.
And this preferential connection between the hydrogen ions and the phosphate ions drives
this entire reaction to the right.
So not only this part of the equilibrium, but also this part of the equilibrium gets dragged
to the right as well.
And that's due to Le Chatelier's principle, which states as we lose molecules on one side
of the equation, the equilibrium seeks to restore that imbalance.
So if hydrogen pulls this reaction to the right, it will also pull this reaction to
the right.
And in doing so, it pulls calcium and phosphate ions out of the tooth.
And this is how sugar and bacteria cause tooth decay.
This is the process we call de-mineralization, which is a super important board exam term.
Now there are also other more direct sources of acid, GERD or acid reflux or frequent vomiting
from bulimia can cause gastric acids to come in contact with teeth, which if chronic can
cause acid erosion.
Also lots of drinks, like soda, have citric, carbonic and phosphoric acids, that can also
increase the hydrogen ion concentration in the mouth, and thus lower the pH of the mouth
even more.
Since soda also has sugar, you get the double whammy effects of both sugar and acid pulling
this entire equilibrium to the right, and literally leaching minerals out of the teeth.
Next let's talk about the Stefan curve, which almost always shows up on the board exam in
some capacity.
We have plotted on the y-axis the pH of the plaque and by extension the mouth and the
oral cavity.
The lower that this pH is, the more acidic the oral environment.
On the x-axis is time in minutes.
So normally the mouth is sitting comfortably up here at around 7 pH, which is neutral.
But when it's exposed to acid, in the form of drinks, food, gastric acid, or what we've
been talking about mostly, lactic acid produced by karyogenic bacteria, the pH of plaque covering
teeth decreases rapidly, hitting a minimum value within about 10 minutes.
You'll notice I have a line going across here at pH 5.5.
This is the critical pH of tooth enamel, the pH at which tooth mineral starts dissolving
in the way that we talked about before.
Anything below the critical pH is when calcium and phosphate ions are actively being leached
out of the tooth.
So the area colored in red is de-mineralization, and the area colored in green is actually
what's called remineralization, and we'll talk about that right now.
So let's revisit our equilibrium diagram.
So we've talked about what can go wrong.
Now let's talk about what can go right.
Saliva is our main natural protector from cavities, and saliva contains bicarbonate, HCO3 negative,
which is a weak base and serves as a buffer for this equilibrium.
Essentially it acts as a distractor and complexes with the extra hydrogen ions to form carbonic
acid.
This means that the rest of the equilibrium here is untouched.
This is now disconnected from what's happening over here because of this handy buffer.
The presence of bicarbonate has neutralized the pH so that the mouth is no longer so acidic,
and we no longer have to pull on the tooth to fix the imbalance that the extra floating
hydrogen ions was causing.
So this allows the tooth the opportunity to regain its strength by re-incorporating calcium
and phosphate ions into its enamel.
In fact, saliva contains calcium, which can drive this reaction to the left, again by
La Chatelier's principle if we have some extra calcium floating around, contributing to what's
known as re-mineralization, restoring mineral to the tooth and hardening the tooth as a
result.
So de-mineralization is destroying or dissolving mineral from tooth, re-mineralization is restoring
mineral to the tooth as long as it hasn't become physically cavitated, and we'll go over that
a little bit later.
There are also products like Am I Paste whose sole purpose is to buffer acids and increase
concentration of these free minerals in saliva, thereby increasing its concentration in the
teeth themselves, shifting the equilibrium to the left, and re-mineralizing the tooth.
Saliva also contains fluoride when a patient is drinking fluoridated water, using fluoridated
mouth rants and toothpaste, and so on.
The why is fluoride so important to tooth health?
Well, as we can see, it re-mineralizes the tooth by driving this reaction to the left,
just like calcium did, and not only that, it replaces the hydroxyl group to make another
form of appetite that we already mentioned before, fluorapitate.
Fluorapitate has a more stable crystal lattice, which doesn't let go of its calcium as easily
as the carbonate substituted hydroxiapitate.
So not only does it make the tooth harder, but it also makes the tooth more resistant
to future acid damage.
So let me show you how that works.
So let's revisit the Stefan curve.
We talked about how it reaches a minimum in about 10 minutes after what I'll call an acid
challenge.
This could be eating breakfast, eating a snack, drinking coffee, et cetera, and it takes
about 30 minutes for the bicarbonate in the saliva to buffer the pH back to normal.
Now chewing sugar-free xylitol gum would actually stimulate saliva production in the mouth,
and cause this curve to return above critical pH faster than it would have without it, because
now we're having more saliva bathing that tooth.
On the other hand, a patient with dry mouth or zerostomia would take well over an hour
to buffer this pH back to normal, because they have less saliva, and they have less
natural protection.
So how pH recovers as a function of how often you eat and drink, how long you eat and drink
for, what you eat, the stickiness of the food, the quality of the saliva, how you brush your
teeth, all of those factors play a role in your carries risk.
So to show you the power of fluoride, let's take a look at this new and improved Stefan
curve for fluorapatite, or FA for short.
For enamel incorporating fluoride, the critical pH is now, it's no longer at 5.5, it's way
down here at 4.5, which means it will take a stronger acid challenge to get below that
and start causing de-mineralization.
So you can visualize the benefits just by looking at the area under the curve, that
initial acid challenge we had before doesn't even reach below it, so this tooth isn't at
risk of de-mineralization at all, and that's the power of fluoride.
So to review, fluoride prevents tooth decay by three distinct mechanisms, and this is
an excellent, excellent board exam question, I would definitely know these three by heart.
So number one, it remineralizes the two structure by shifting the equilibrium to the left, in
our example, it decreases enamel solubility, it lowers, and that's by lowering that critical
pH, and I haven't mentioned this yet, but also important, it interferes with the metabolic
activity of the karyogenic bacteria, three unique mechanisms all working in tandem to
prevent tooth decay, pretty cool stuff.
So important for the board exam, I've mentioned the first two in passing, but just to give
you a nice snapshot of these really important numbers to know, enamel that has fluoride,
fluorapatite, that's a 4.5, it's our best critical pH, carbonate substituted hydroxyapatite
is at 5.5, and then root, dentin, and cementum is somewhere up here between 6.2 and 6.7.
So you can see it's a lot more vulnerable, and this is why exposed root surfaces are
more susceptible to acid erosion and tooth decay, because their threshold is much closer
to the physiologic normal pH, and so those surfaces are way more vulnerable to acid challenges.
So carries, the multi-factorial, transmissible, infectious, dynamic oral disease, that is
a mouthful, no pun intended, so carries is the result of, as you know by now, an interaction
of karyogenic oral flora, which form a plaque or biofilm with fermentable dietary carbohydrates,
the sugars we talked about on the tooth surface, which is the host of the disease, and it has
to be over a period of time.
So the initial diagram to describe carries was plaque, tooth, and diet, and having all
three of those together would cause carries, but it's better modeled by the modified key's
Jordan diagram, which is down here.
This adds a fourth circle of time, because it takes time for this stuff to develop.
And there's so, and actually there's so many other factors that you can see in the top left
and the top right here, there's saliva, pH, fluoride, hygiene, all the things that we've
touched on throughout this video, and again, most importantly, we need time for a cavity
to happen.
This isn't something that's happening overnight, and this is how the modified diagram came
to be.
So it's a balance between de-mineralization and remineralization, pathologic, and protective
factors, like a seesaw going up and down, the constant tug of war between the good and
the bad, and carries is something we manage as dentists, not only at the tooth level,
but holistically at the total patient level.
Again we're talking about things like diet and hygiene, that's at a holistic level.
So let's get into the nitty-gritty, these next couple of sides I guarantee you are going
to be filled to the brim with some really, really good board exam stuff.
So definitely take note of some of this red text, I guarantee you it's going to pop up
on that exam.
So bacteria like to make a home in the deep pits and fissures of teeth, where toothbrush
bristles struggle to reach, and so the bacteria just sit there, they secrete their lactic acid,
and go untouched.
So when it's a pit and fissure lesion, you get this inverted V shape, which means it
starts out narrow, and as it penetrates through the enamel, it gets wider until it reaches
the dentin enamel junction.
By contrast, a smooth surface lesion, this can be on the facial surface near the gumline,
but most commonly it's on the musular distal surface right up against an adjacent tooth.
This is the opposite situation, it starts out wide and narrows out until it reaches the
dentin enamel junction.
At which point dentin is a lot easier to penetrate than enamel, so it spreads out again, kind
of forms this double arrowhead and then penetrates deeper and deeper until it gets treated.
And lastly we have root surface lesions over here on the right, and as we talked about,
they can progress rapidly because there's no enamel, no it's a V shape, just like this
smooth surface lesion, as the root surface is also a smooth surface.
And again, we talked about the critical pH being much higher, hence why it can progress
so much quicker.
We also have to distinguish between infected dentin and a-fected dentin.
So infected dentin refers to this superficial, wet, soft, mushy, necrotic dentin.
That's this stuff, it's easily removed and it has to be removed, because bacteria are
present there, this is a site of active infection.
Whereas a-fected dentin is deeper, it's dry, it's leathery, it's demineralized, but not
invaded by bacteria.
So that's a little bit deeper in this cavity preparation.
You can also see how they're distinguished in this awesome diagram, we have infected
dentin on top, and then a-fected dentin down here.
You also get some sclerotic dentin, that's where the dentin is a little bit harder and
tries to resist the passage of carries deeper and deeper into the tooth.
And a-fected dentin is a-fected by bacterial toxins and acids, but again the actual bacteria
have not made a home there yet.
So it's usually okay to leave a-fected dentin at the base of your prep, particularly if
you're close to the pulp and you're worried about exposing it.
So let's talk a little bit more about progress of lesions.
We can have an intact surface, which is essential for that remineralization process.
So we need that enamel to be intact for there to be remineralization, the equilibrium driving
to the left.
Cavitation, a nick or a hole, is an irreversible process that now requires restorative treatment.
We cannot remineralize a cavitation back to a smooth intact surface.
Cavitation is irreversible.
And like I said, this takes time.
It may take one to two years to form an actual enamel cavitation or cavity.
So from a white spot to a cavitation can take one to two years.
That's a long, long time.
So that's this tug of war between remineralization and demineralization occurring over years and
the demineralization finally winning.
So the order, and I have seen this as a board exam question by itself, is enamel demonization
first.
The surface remains intact.
Then we get dentin demineralization.
So start to see just little evidences of these tiny little demineralized regions of dentin.
And then we get that enamel cavitation.
So this is our irreversible stage where that we can actually feel a cavity there.
And then we get dentin cavitation where that cavity progresses much, much more quickly at
that point.
So enamel demon, dentin demin, enamel cavitation, dentin cavitation.
That is the order of a cavity.
So some really good terms to know.
We're going to talk about Keri's terms with regards to extent of the lesion first.
So an incipient lesion or a reversible lesion occurs when it occurs on a smooth surface.
You're going to notice this very specific quality.
It appears opaque white when it's air dried, but it seems to go away when it's wet.
So we'll talk about that a little bit more in the next video when we talk about the clinical
exam, how we look for Keri's and detect them.
But that is an important thing to know for the incipient Keri's lesion.
So if we're talking about incipient, we're kind of in this enamel demon, maybe dentin
demon, there's some controversy there, but we're certainly not at the cavitation point.
So incipient, we're in this safe zone where we can reverse the process back to normal.
And then on the flip side, we have the cavitated or irreversible lesion where the enamel surface
is broken, it's no longer intact, and usually the lesion has advanced into dentin.
Again, we see now we're on this half, so we're starting off in incipient lesion territory,
we can reverse it, then at this point, we're no longer reversible.
So that's incipient and cavitated.
Now let's talk about Keri's terms with regards to the location.
Really good stuff here.
A simple cavity, simple Keri's lesion, covers one surface of a tooth.
Also occlusal is the most common simple lesion you'll find on a posterior tooth.
If you're curious, this is also true for a restoration.
So restorations are also given, they can also be classified by these first three terms here.
So simple one surface, compound is two surfaces.
So mesial occlusal, distal occlusal.
Complex means it covers three or more surfaces of the tooth.
So MOD, or it could be MODFL, it could be all five surfaces of a tooth.
So this is Keri's terms with regards to how many surfaces that cavity is affecting, and
the restoration to fix that can also be defined by those same terms.
Down here we have the primary Keri's lesion.
A primary lesion is the original Keri's lesion.
So in other words, it's the first time lesion on that surface.
You have a virgin tooth that's never been affected by a cavity before.
You notice a cavity on the occlusal surface of it, that's a primary lesion.
Now if you had a tooth that already had a restoration, let's say on the mesial surface,
but it never had anything on the distal surface, and the dentist notices that the distal surface
now is decay, that distal surface is also a primary lesion, because it's the first time
that surface got decay.
In contrast, we have the secondary or recurrent Keri's lesion, and this occurs at the junction
of a tooth and a restoration indicating micro leakage underneath that restoration.
There is marginal gap, bacteria got in there, so it created that lactic acid and created
another cavity.
So it's Keri's that's born from another lesion that had already been restored, but now we
have decay underneath it.
This is important to distinguish from residual, which kind of, it seems like the same thing
at first, but it's distinctly different.
So residual Keri's residual lesion refers to Keri's that remain in a completed tooth
prep.
So that means that we did the preparation and immediately after that preparation's done,
there still Keri's there, that lesion was not completely removed.
Sometimes that's done on purpose, but most of the time it's not, and it's an unfortunate
thing when that happens that Keri's was left behind, and that is residual Keri's.
Recurrent Keri's occurs when that restoration was done, Keri's was completely removed, and
then at a later date Keri's now affected that area.
So some really good location terms.
Let's finish this off with Keri's terms that have to do with the rate of the decay progression.
So we have up here a cute or rampant Keri's, this is where you get rapid damage to the
tooth structure, it's lightly colored, it feels soft, and it's infectious.
In contrast, chronic or slow Keri's means we have de-mineralized tooth structure that's
almost remineralized, it's discolored, it's fairly hard, it's progressing at a slower rate.
That tug of war is not so one-sided like it was with acute, it's a little bit more balanced,
we're getting a little bit more remineralization to help fight off that progression.
And then we can have arrested lesions that appear brown or black, they're hard to the
touch, and their Keri's resistant if exposed to fluoride.
So this is a cavity that has completely, has been arrested completely, the equilibrium
is not moving in the direction of de-mineralization, which is a good thing.
And if it's in the dentin, we get that sclerotic dentin, that's that hard dentin that is laid
down by the odonna blast to protect the tooth from further ingress of bacteria.
So if we look down here, which of these looks worse to you?
And maybe at first glance you'd say, well, the one on the right looks darker and just
more formidable in some ways.
But knowing what you know now, that's actually an arrested lesion.
And so that's a good thing.
And if you examine that with an explorer, it would be hard to the touch, whereas the
left one would be soft, and that is an active rampant Keri's lesion.
That's an active Keri's lesion, it's actively progressing, and that one certainly needs
to be restored.
The arrested one, maybe if they're not, if you're not concerned with the overall health
of the tooth, there's no pulp exposure, it's sound, there's no risk of fracture, it could
be left alone unless the aesthetics bothers the patient, but of course it would be best
to restore that as well because that's just a retentive area for food and plaque to get
in there.
So in the periodontic series, we talked about the different microbiological hypotheses for
gum disease.
For Keri's, it's pretty simple.
We abide primarily by the specific plaque hypothesis, where only specific bacteria in
the oral cavity cause Keri's, and those are carogenic bacteria.
So let's talk about three specific bacteria that are most intimately related with dental
Keri's.
The big one, Streptococcus mutans, this one is the big bad for enamel Keri's, it's a
gram-positive coccye, and it produces glucoseal transferase, or GTF, which converts sucrose,
which is kind of a main sugar from most of our foods that we're eating.
It converts that to glucans and fructoseans, which are extracellular polysaccharides that
help the bacteria stick to the tooth.
So these glucans and fructoseans are kind of like slime and this sticky stuff that helps
the bacteria adhere to the tooth.
So really bad for us, good for the bacteria.
It's also acidogenic and aciduric.
We know it's acidogenic, which means it converts the sucrose into lactic acid via fermentation,
which we talked about in our big equilibrium diagram.
And also it's aciduric, it's durable in acid, it tolerates the acid well.
So it can bathe in its own secretion, so to speak, and it doesn't get damaged or killed
from having low pH, it actually likes it.
And it also produces bacteria sins, which means it can kill off competing microbes.
So this thing is nasty, and it is definitely the main cause of enamel carries, and certainly
a really, really important one to know for the board exam and for life moving forward.
We also have lactobacillus, which is the primary cause of dentinol carries and actinomyces,
which is the primary cause for root carries.
So this is a bit of an oversimplification, but I definitely think it's helpful to know
for the board exam.
It just kind of keeps it easy, and you just have to think of one bacteria for one region
or one zone of the tooth that's affected by carries.
And so I've talked a lot about what can go wrong in the carries process.
We also touched on remineralization, and so as you know, the main natural protective element
is saliva, so saliva can come to the rescue, of course, brushing your teeth is the best
thing you can do, but saliva contains a lot of great stuff to help us out.
So it has glycoproteins up here, these large molecules that can agglutinate bacteria together,
just glue them and stick them all together to help eliminate them through swallowing.
So they get stuck altogether and get swallowed with a bolus of food, urea and other buffers,
like bicarbonate that we talked about, dilutes the bacterial acid byproducts, helps drive
the reaction to the right, it contains lysosine, which destroys cell walls, so that's really
useful, it can kill bacteria, damage them, lactofarin, actively binds iron, which is
important for bacterial enzymes, so it steals away the iron that the bacteria like to use,
iron that ferris that's coming in here, and lacto, I like to remember, act from lacto
inactivate, and then iron, of course, related to this stem of the word, so lactofarin in
activates iron, and then we have lactoparoxidase, which inactivates bacterial enzymes, so again,
we have act here, so we're inactivating aces, which are enzymes, so that's how I keep these
two things straight and they almost always pop up on the board exam, so just a little
helpful memory tip there.
saliva also contains salivary IgA, which is a menoglobulin A, it's a salivary antibody
that's specifically made against bacteria in the oral cavity, of course saliva is also
containing calcium, phosphate, and fluoride ions that help with remineralization, you
know all about that by now, and also contains these other things that can help promote the
remineralization process.
Alright, so that's it for this video guys, thank you so much for watching, I really hope
you enjoyed it, I think this is a fascinating topic, and some really good stuff for the
board exam, but also just some really fun stuff to learn about, so hopefully you enjoyed
it as much as I did.
Please like this video if you did give it a thumbs up and subscribe to this channel for
much more on dentistry, if you're interested in supporting this channel and what I do,
please check out my patreon page, thank you to Michael Raja, Rev Boyd, David Jaden, Isabella
Kaldis, Ali Benjjjir, Badir Hefnawi, and all of my Patrons for their support, you can
unlock extras like access to my video slides to take notes on, and practice questions for
the board exam.
So go check that out, the link is in the description.
Thanks again for watching everyone, I'll see you in the next video.